we're not sure what was going on at
cartoon network's standards and
practices department but either someone
was incredibly permissive or incredibly
gullible because the powerpuff girls
writers managed to slip an unbelievable
amount of stuff into the show that's
highly inappropriate for children here
are things only adults notice and the
powerpuff girls
if you're a connoisseur of hidden
vulgarity you'll find that the dirtiest
jokes in the powerpuff girls tend to be
hidden in plain sight
usually on signage during establishing
shots one of the more
obvious examples occurred in the season
2 episode down and dirty
at one point buttercup fights a monster
alongside a truck for a septic tank
company called bob septic world this
company has a somewhat obvious yet
nonetheless hilarious tagline
quote we're full of it but perhaps the
most hidden and most indecent joke in
all of the powerpuff girls occurs in the
season 2 episode
some things are miss that's where we see
miss bellum's house for the first time
not only is her first name sarah and
last name bellam a funny pun but
according to the address on her mailbox
she
lives at 69 yoda linda valley lane the
number is a pretty famous slang and
yodel in the valley
is a somewhat more obscure yet no less
suggestive turn of phrase
the mayor of townsville usually seems
about as chaste as they come
a cuddly and dopey little old man but we
occasionally get to see the mez in a
psyche and whenever we do we find a sea
of dirty thoughts hanging out just
beneath the surface
our first hint comes in the season 2
episode a very special blossom when the
girls are trying to raise money to buy a
father's day gift for professor utonium
because they don't have an actual source
of income
they ask the mayor for money as back
payment for all of their super heroism
the mayor shuts them down with the
provocative line
i know sugar daddy those days are over
things got even more obvious in the
episode some things are missed a super
villain seducer
impersonates the mayor's assistant miss
bellum and uses her feminine wiles to
persuade the mayor to help her commit
crime
after seducer is thrown in jail the
mayor continues to flirt with the real
miss bellum
until she explains that the woman
flirting with him earlier was a super
villain and not actually her the mayor
probably excuses himself after ms
bellamast where he's going and says
to the prison visiting hours are almost
over
poodles despite all the attempts to
think of the mayor as nothing but a
teddy bear lines like this make it clear
that he is still very much
sugar spice and everything nice the
first time the evil rowdy rough boys
appear they act like elementary
school-aged boys
down to their fart-based attack powers
the girls eventually learn that the
boy's weakness is anything feminine
so they defeat the gang by kissing them
on the cheeks the second time they
appear
the rowdy rough boys have new haircuts
and they have grown up a little
acting more like middle schoolers the
girls discover that their old enemies
have now lost their previous weakness
now being kissed makes them grow larger
and become more powerful
we don't need to hit the metaphor too
hard for you to get this but their
symbolism and the boys growing up a bit
and having a kiss from a girl no longer
destroy them but instead make them
well larger but the girls later discover
that emasculating the boys can reverse
this process
by mocking and belittling them they
shrink back to their normal size
and shrink even further until the girls
can hold them in the palms of their
hands
blossom even states at one point did you
say that
whenever their masculinity is threatened
they shrink
in size
toxic masculinity does indeed ruin the
party yet again
theatrical films often have difficulty
showing blood without getting an r
rating
but somehow the powerpuff girls will
regularly leave villains on a bloody
heap on a y7 rated show the gals also
often inflict serious levels of
collateral damage on townsville and
whether or not
innocent citizens are hurt israeli
addressed it's sometimes even implied
that the powerpuff girls enjoy
inflicting violence on villains like in
the season 3 episode
candy is dandy when the girls filled
with rage take
beating up mojo jojo a little too far
after he steals some of their candy
but physical violence isn't the only
punishment the powerpuff girls attack
with in the season two episode dream
scheme we meet the sandman the
mythological figure responsible for
putting people to sleep but
since he's always working he's never
able to stop and get some sleep himself
a sandman has a plan to put the entire
world to sleep so that he can finally
get some shut-eye
after this works and the powerpuff girls
along with everyone else get trapped in
dreamland their solution is entering his
dreams and scaring him so bad that's
quote he'll never want to sleep again
the poor overworked creature leaps out
of bed and gets right back to work
vowing to never sleep again a hollow
smile now plastered across his
traumatized face
much of the powerpuff girls and
appropriate content occurs in small
moments but the season five episode's
shotgun wedding is raunchy throughout
professor utonium travels into the woods
to study fuzzy lumpkins a recurring
villain who is a sort of hillbilly
bigfoot a gun-wielding pink-third
monster
while tracking lumpkins the professor
falls into some mud getting a muddy lump
on his face that resembles a big round
nose lumpkins then spots utonium and
because of the mud mistakes utonium for
a female from his own species
after the powerpuff girls discovered
that lumpkins has captured their dad
intending to marry him they interrupt
the wedding and beat up fuzzy they also
accidentally injured the professor a bit
momentarily confusing him for a lumpkin
the girls apologize profusely but the
professor remains grateful
he saves rubbing his bruised butt it's
okay i can think of much worse things
that could have happened the professor
cleans himself off leaving behind a
muddy pile on the ground fuzzy clearly
upset
screams
but fuzzy just scoops up the mud carries
it into a shack and
completely ignores a professor the
noises that then emanate from within
cannot be interpreted as anything other
than lumpkins consummating his marriage
to a pile of wet dirt
not all of the mature references on the
powerpuff girls are about sex
some are just jokes about movies and
music that are so adult oriented that
the kids have no idea what it is
in the season 2 episode cootie gra there
are multiple tributes to the godfather
including the phrase quotes make you an
offer you can't refuse and a recreation
of the final shot of the film and
in dream scheme an episode in which all
of the dialogue rhymes the show
recreates that does anybody want a
peanut joke from the princess bride the
power buff girls writers also show that
they're fans of the coen brothers on two
occasions there's the episode some
things are missed which features an
extended tribute to the fireplace scene
from the big lebowski the mayor even
quotes the line
are you surprised by my tears strong men
also cry there's also an episode of the
show called the headsuckers moxie a
clear nod to the hudsucker proxy but the
most extended joke in the entire series
has to be the episode meet the beatles
it's theoretically an episode in which
many of the powerpuffs most dangerous
foes form an alliance to defeat them but
it's just a plot designed to deliver
puns based around the titles of beatles
songs the creators must have had fun
with the show's budget
generally speaking most comedians
realize that mocking people who have
been abused is immoral and not
particularly funny but for some reason
cartoons have found a loophole in this
rule a subgroup of people who they are
fine with making jokes about and that's
men who were victimized in prison
once you start to realize this trend you
see that jokes about prison assaults are
disturbingly common in entertainment of
all ages
from marvel films to spongebob
squarepants but the powerpuff girls
makes a prison joke in several episodes
in cootie gra
mojo jojo is defeated yet again by the
powerpuff girls the episode ends with
him tossed into a prison cell alongside
another villain a stereotypically burly
tough guy
love is in the air can't you just
smell it there's even a call back to the
joke in the episode
monkey see doggy 2. mojo has been
transformed into a dog and finds himself
in the dog pound stuck
next to the similarly large and imposing
bulldog equivalent of his last cellmate
most of the hidden dirty jokes in the
powerpuff girls still make us laugh but
looking back at these specific jokes
it's hard to find them funny or
acceptable
even though the powerpuff girls were
made by mixing together some chemicals
in a lab we get a sign in the very first
episode mommy furious that the professor
has indeed told them about other forms
of making babies and the importance of
staying protected
professor utonium has just met a woman
he liked at the supermarket
and even though he is too stunned to
speak to her the girls proved that
they're the ultimate wingman when they
asked the woman out on the professor's
behalf
as he gets ready for his date the girls
continue to help him out by applying
hair gel
cologne feeding him breath mints and
attaching his cufflinks but buttercup
slips something into his jacket pocket
that she refers to as quote some of
these
it's an extremely quick shot and we
don't actually see what she gave him but
what else could that be
the show seems to be heavily implying
that buttercup must have slipped the
professor some protection
just another way that the powerpuff
girls always make sure that the people
of townsville are staying safe
it isn't often that an entire character
is created solely as a vessel for dirty
jokes but that's what we have in the
case of the villain max q max from the
episode
members only he's a hairy muscular robot
from outer space here to conquer the
earth and he communicates exclusively
through double entendres max humerus
first appears in a meeting of the
association of world supermen
and says men of earth witness the coming
of maxumus breaker of men
taker of wells be there any true men
amongst thee step four
then bring thy manhood against my own
so that we might see who has the ability
upon the measure instinct
there are at least five risque jokes in
that line alone but it's totally
possible that summer missed mascu max
only sticks around for a few minutes of
screen time but he crams in a shocking
amount of dirty jokes not long after he
shows up
the girls are able to defeat him by
putting their powers together and
transforming into a giant cat made of
fire known as the furious flaming feline
in the season six episode twas the fight
before christmas the girls end up at the
north pole
they learn that in addition to its
naughty and nice list santa also has a
permanent naughty list with only four
names three of them are references to
key members of the show's creative team
craig mccracken lauren faust and steve
fonte but the fourth name seems to be a
reference to a far more naughty and far
more real evil doer
the fourth name on santa's permanent
naughty plaque is adolf shikor gruber a
name which is thought to be the birth
name of adolf hitler if santa does
indeed have a permanent naughty plaque
it would certainly make sense for this
real-life villain's name to be on it but
there's no actual evidence that hitler
ever had the last name shikor gruber
shikor gruber was a surname
hitler's father was given at birth but
he changed it to hitler over a decade
before adolf was born
it's possible that the writers of the
powerpuff girls believed this urban
legend about the birth name but it's far
more likely that this bit of
misdirection
is the only way the writers can slide a
real world bad guy into a kids show
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one